la première impression juge qu'intel
intérieure et sa main d'un mur ou
système mois de janvier 1981 en tant
qu'aide à 12
je veux écouter la fameuse cassette
qu'une voix ex transneft quand je l'aï
vu il était tout petit parce qu'elle en
dit beaucoup
vers l'âge de 14 15 ans comme tous les
adolescents à elle était toute petite
tucci veulent ma première impression je
me suis dit ce poète et chanter sauvé la
cassette
alors où j'espère en tout cas que ce
soit elle n'est je veux dit doté j'avais
hâte qu'elle chante
kovailanen dans le bureau et là elle
s'est mise à chanter puis c'est
incroyable non seulement ce terre comme
un destin meilleur la casse et
évidemment ça me touche énormément
elle a comme changer de personnalité ça
me touchait beaucoup beaucoup j'ai même
que je ferai la fin la chanson ça a été
relativement simple parce que tout le
travail que j'avais fait plonger notre
nous pas impuni
ça c'est à dire rencontrer un auteur
compositeur extraordinaire eddy marnay
une compagnie ce faire une entente avec
une compagnie turque en france
à ce moment là c'était irma et pathé
marconi
tout ce travail avait été fait donc et
et et a eu cette rupture avec ginette
reno et par une coïncidence incroyable
j'ai rencontré céline dion deux semaines
après tout était en place
évidemment pour une chanteuse
ça prend les chansons de des bonnes
chansons plus les chanteurs sont bons
plus âpre un bon matériel
alors on pourrait pas avoir mieux qu'à
des marnais et je le connaissais des
gestes à mon grand ami on avait
travaillé pour ginette renouent donc
tout est en place neuf carrés à 10 est
venu pile entendu selene pour la
première fois il ya eu la même réaction
- lui aussi la pleurer et mais lui plus
fort que moi y'a pas un titre d'une
chanson la voix du bon dieu
qu'il a écrite de la journée main et sa
carrière française a commencé comme ça
ça me blesse
sam baisse énorme m
elle par contre ça ne passe pas monsieur
la tête mais vous ça vous plaît moi ça
me blesse parce que je connais les gens
du métier ça fait tellement longtemps
celle un métier ici je connais tout le
travail que ça prend pour être rendue où
on est rendu
je suis ce que ça représente pour le
québec aussi
et et s'abaisse cas c'est une critique
sur des chansons sur un disque sont
performance semblait sport au contraire
je vois des choses positives la main et
souvent c'est arrivé de changer des
choses dans notre spectacle ou un truc
comme ça en lisant une critique ça ça me
dérange pas mais des mesquineries sur sa
personnalité sur sa personne
ça me blesse énormément comme tous les
amène dis-je devrait même pas m'en faire
avec ça mais c'est fort que moi je m'en
fais je gêne être humain qui aime vivre
au québec qui aime qui québécois
même si pendant maman chantal ans
l'église qu'on travaille là bas ça c'est
une autre chose qui me choque beaucoup
quand quelqu'un parle de sérénades 5
qu'elle est américain nous parce qu'elle
traverse vegas il ya pas plus québécoise
celle de sa famille si ces choses qui me
choquent
il ya eu des gens au québec six heures
que je les blancs parce que quand tu es
quelqu'un que la petite fée ce lundi aux
québécois devient vedette aux états unis
surtout j'ai blanc pas de penser que
goethe a prévenu foot est un peu mais
moi je savais de quoi je parlais je
connaissais son talent son âme
c'est sa détermination sont
professionnels et son professionnalisme
son plein je savais qu'elle tout ce
qu'il fallait pour réussir je suis
abonné à verbe atteint aussi quitte une
agence qui qui qui nous envoient par
écrit tout ce qui est dit sur celle d'un
monde ainsi donc je sais tout ce qui
était grippe ce qui est dit sur scène ce
qu'il faut avoir faim à ce moment là ce
contrôle de l'énergie
comment on n'avait pas passé suppression
de contrôler une question de est
intéressé à ton produit mais n'importe
quelle présidente compagnie serait
intéressé de savoir ce qu'on dit sur son
produit partout dans le monde
moi ça m'intéresse que les gens disent
de sin je m'excuse si je parle de
produits parce que je fins de
comparaison avec les compagnies avaient
tout ce qui se passe dans nos mains des
affaires mais ça m'intéresse beaucoup ce
qui se dit sur scène ça m'intéresse pas
je serai pas serait pas en tapant deux
situations poésie j'ai pas
e
pourrait pas prendre des décisions pitt
savoir parce que souvent ce qu'ils
disent c'est comme jeter 10 90 % du
temps ces gens ont raison c'est comme ça
que je peux tâter le pouls du public des
populations puisqu'on parlait tout à
l'heure de ce qui me fait de la peine
c'est l'autre même pas 10% j'irai
peut-être cinq pour ça mais je veux
savoir ce qui se dit sur scène ça
m'intéresse c'est ma vie c'est ma femme
opus puis peut-être c'est pour ça que ça
me choque plus parce que si c'était
uniquement mon artiste sûreté capable de
passer par dessus les mesquineries
il ya des gens qui vont accuser d'avoir
un contrôle absolu sur les médias au
québec c'est un mythe sont où c'est vrai
parce que soient apposés d'éléphants ça
va pas faire puis c'est un m parce que
quelqu'un qui fait bien son travail fait
exactement ce que je fais si je peux
contente qu'elle change pas un téléphone
le pen jeudi 6h en piégeant question qui
disent que je sais dans mon le contrôle
c'est leur problème nous sommes mon
travail je suis fait mon travail mon
travail consiste à gérer la carrière de
celle du mieux que je peux le show
business c'est un endroit où tout est
possible
j'ai vu des gens boire beaucoup j'ai vu
des gens se droguer beaucoup ans j'ai vu
des gants et des gens ou là où le côté
grandiose des choses où le succès le
succès des choses leurs mots quand on
dit le succès lui monte à la taille
je pense qu'il faut toujours être
conscients dessous moi je veux toujours
un peu avoir par dessus parce que je
veux pas tomber dans un piège
est ce que c'est parce que je me fais
pas ci que l'on commença ses interviewés
soi même alors je peux pas faire ça je
pense pas c'est continuellement montant
m'interviewer moi même c'est pas c'est
pas mon genre de toute façon mais pour
moi elle consciente de ce que tout le
monde veut tout donner
pas de problème je te ranger sous tout
est possible quand j'avais rien à 20
personnes avaient rien donné
maintenant que je peux m'offrir tout le
monde de toute donnée gratuit je veux
vraiment pas je veux toujours être gardé
un petit doute que on peut encore tomber
dans le piège parce que je pense que je
me préserve jeu mais je fais attention à
moi
danse école je veux faire attention à
candy comprend les choses pour un qui
peut on dire pas de problème je suis
forte je me fais confiance
oui on peut il faut se faire confiance
mais il faut aussi garder un petit doute
comme de quoi quand j'étais perdre la
carte c'est à dire que c'était ça peut
tellement être facile de justement est
dans les points et et puis j'ai jamais
voulu faire partie du show business se
trouve je veux faire je veux faire
partie je veux faire un peu de show biz
mais je ne peux pas cracher dessus
j'ai pas besoin de ça